[Music]
the NHS is close to crisis this
Christmas a combination of seasonal
strained and staff on strike and now
more action confirmed by nurses
including Carmel O'Boyle who says it's
an agonizing decision I have colleagues
who are using food banks and because
they can't afford to feed their families
and that has again a knock-on effect
onto patient care you can't expect
somebody to be looking after you know
someone else if you can't look after
your own it's really difficult nurses
want the Prime Minister sat down for
talks they say salaries aren't enough to
deliver the care patients need
with the Prime Minister visiting a
charity won't move on pay I'm really sad
and disappointed about the disruption
that has been caused to so many people's
lives particularly at Christmas time you
know when it comes to it was a difficult
question of setting public sector pay
the government has acted fairly
unreasonably in accepting all the
recommendations of the public sector pay
review bodies that's an independent
process the government has listened to
but nurses say the reviews he talks of
were inadequate and tens of thousands
will walk out again so after the strikes
that happened last week the government
still continues ignoring what nurses are
saying and and therefore we feel we've
got no choice than to take action again
in January to try and again send a very
strong signal to the government that
unless they come back to the table this
will need to continue the NHS has never
faced such industrial action nurses went
on strike on the 15th and 20th of
December while ambulance workers walked
out on the 21st and it continues in the
new year with nursing strikes on the
18th and 19th of January and more
ambulance staff action on the 11th and
23rd nurses in school Scotland will also
strike in the new year
the problem is this is the busiest
period for the NHS services and staff
are under immense pressure with the
triple challenge of flu covered and
other viruses
the industrial action is disruptive and
in deadlock leaving uncertainty for
patients and a winter of discomfort for
the Health Service Laura bundock Sky
News